Could you please offer advice for
individuals with high intelligence but
low extroversion and low agreeableness
and making and maintaining social
connections and friendships?
Well,
I would.
That's Roger,
Roger.
I would say make a plan.
Again,
spend some time on it weekly.
Go to things like meetups.
There's a site called meetup.com.
That's a good place to meet people.
Do whatever you have to to meet people.
Take a course,
strike up a conversation and ask
questions and listen.
That's particularly good if you're low
in agreeableness,
um,
people really like to be listened to.
You don't want to pester them with
questions too badly,
but you can get an awful long ways by
listening to people and asking them
questions people hardly ever get
listened to and they're so damn happy
when you do it that,
um,
that,
that they're likely to open themselves.